hello everyone and welcome to
rational science directly from frankfurt
germany
we have a busy day today and so i'm
going to get
right to it we divide our show in three
parts the first part we deal with
extinction second part we're going to be
dealing with physics
today is spin we all know what spin
is you know you take a top you spin it
no problem piece of cake
and then after that we're going to do
some of the answer try to answer some of
the questions and
comments that people make okay let's get
right to it
i've held that if the united states
government happens to fall by that i
mean you know the
economy happens to collapse to disappear
to disintegrate that's the end of it for
the world
because the united states is such a the
american empire so big it's got its
tentacles everywhere
uh it's too big to fail okay so
we all would do well in propping up the
united states government especially that
one because it's the biggest government
on earth
okay and so the question for you today
i've got a couple questions that's the
first one is going to be
is the united states government
collapsing
is it disintegrated is it imploding
losing ground and uh you see some of the
problems that you hear out there one of
them is
us protests there's
riots quite often lately
okay they're pulling out of afghanistan
assessment says that maybe in about six
months
the taliban are back in power after so
many years 20 years of fighting
then we have the problem with iran saudi
arabia and israel
that's an ongoing one
we have big problems in haiti honduras
guatemala
in the caribbean uh
tied to that cuba also starting to have
riots communist country with riots can
you believe that
north korea they don't have riots they
have starvation
unless the chinese feed them uh then we
south america brazil colombia argentina
peru all with
major major problems a lot of it brought
about by the
measures taken by the governments
because of this covid stuff
okay but they're all suffering lots of
people who
are out of work especially in the
tourist industry that's what happened to
cuba by the way
tourism stopped uh you know tourism was
became an important part of the cuban
economy
and then suddenly it collapsed so yeah
it's a big problem for the cubans
um chinese on the other hand seem to be
doing pretty
good yeah they're expanding into africa
especially also in other regions
uh at the uh cost of the united states
okay then you have a russia china
pact you know they've got a couple
economic and military packs out there
uh treaties and so on you have
brexit uh happened just a little while
ago uh
is this the breakup the beginning of the
breakup of the european union
at the bottom you see that that's a
right in indonesia today you had another
one or
the numbers came out for south africa
there's riots everywhere and you better
get used to them because
riots are going to be very popular
people going out in the streets and
protesting
is something going on is something
unusual going on
a lot of people might say well you know
there's always been problems
uh problem between countries within
countries and so on
uh i think this is a little different
what we're seeing now okay i think what
we're staring at is or hearing
out there is it's a little different
than what's happened in the past
i'll tell you why a big problem that we
have today
is that we're not we're not expanding
our population
is stagnating and
because of all these problems you know
the corporations
are now going to be apparently they're
going to be taxed at a higher rate okay
and here you see there's uh there's news
came out
global tax reform plan goes to the g20
okay and the g20 and other countries as
well you know they decided to
tax the corporations at a higher rate
and part of the reason is that you know
a lot of people have lost their jobs
and there's not much you can tax from
someone who's
receiving welfare and so what happens is
uh you know the the governments have to
get the money somewhere else and so they
want to tax the corporations
instead of 12 percent they want to
inject it up to 15 percent
apparently a lot of countries are in
agreement with that
except a couple like you know ireland
for example they don't like that idea
because
they entice companies such as google
apple
and facebook to install their
headquarters in ireland in exchange for
giving them
good tax breaks and now the european
union and other countries are
saying well you know you got to tax them
a little higher because we all have to
be more or less at the same level
and there are some countries that just
don't like that because they're
receiving the benefits today
of low taxes and so on so you know one
of the issues you got to think about is
whether
uh it's a good deal to tax major
corporations
okay okay
but what is the problem as i see it this
is the problem and here's a map
that puts it puts it on the back okay
these are the cities of the world uh the
big cities of the world
more or less how population is
distributed and i've circled regions
major regions on the planet where
there's a
few people almost no people maybe a
village here or there
these regions are empty you could almost
say there are more empty regions than
filled regions on the planet okay
what's the problem well the problem is
that everybody
is moving to the cities we have not
created new cities in the last hundred
years
in any significant way what we've done
is
people have moved from the country to
some cities made them big
made others even bigger but what we're
doing is abandoning the countryside to
the big corporations that do agriculture
and we're not founding new cities in you
know new villages new towns
uh in those uh empty regions
and the question is are we ever going to
do that
is this ever going to happen are we
going to fill those
regions uh that i've circled there
are are we ever going to create new
cities
and i don't think so how would a
government create a new city just force
people you know with a gun and take them
out there to the fields and say you're
going to have to live here
from now on is that the way it's done
and even if they do that the question is
whether they're going to you know have
children
which is another issue and here you
see some of the numbers for some of the
big countries to see what's going on
this is the big picture okay here's
russia population decline more than
doubles in 2020 one article that i saw
over there
russian population declined more than
doubled uh
in 2020. okay russia's population total
146 million as of january so and so down
to
down from 146.75 they lost 700
000 people last year
and um japan population fell
by 868 000 in five years
over five years uh 2020 census shows
uh the united states what the 2020
census will reveal about america
stagnating growth
and aging population and youthful
diversity
and recently released census bureau
population
estimates show that from july 1 2019 to
july 1 2020 one year right the nation
grew by just
0.35 percent this is the lowest annual
growth rate
since at least 1900
we're not having children and part of
the reasons is we're not creating cities
and part of the reason is that everybody
from the country is moving to
existing cities and making making them
you know these megalopolis uh
gigantic monster cities uh
ant holes as i call them and here's
europe
okay just so you can see the numbers how
to tackle population decline in europe's
regions
one article okay rural area make up to
44 percent of the eu's surface but 78
percent
of the european population lives in
urban areas or functional
urban areas how about africa well the
uni
continent seems to be growing africa
population will triple by the end of the
century
even as the rest of the world shrinks it
says africa will only will be the only
region in the world where population
will still be growing at the end of the
century
given a 48 population decline expected
where
in china yeah believe it or not uh
china is going to go down according to
the estimates and it says nigeria will
become the second biggest country by
2100 and it goes in there and says by
2100 up to 183 countries will have
fertility rates
lower than 2.1 births per women which is
what's considered
as the replacement rate
okay so this is the situation
and and so the question is uh whether
there's any chance whatsoever of us ever
expanding again you know uh if you go
back to the 14th century mid-century
there was apparently the bubonic plague
killed anywhere from one-third to half
of the population of europe
and after that we got rid of the rats
the fleas right
and population started growing back
again why because it was a young
population
disease kept us down when it wasn't the
uh
the bubonic plague it was maybe smallpox
or or the childhood diseases you know
rubiola and one of those
and it would kill a lot of the kids and
it would also kill
the endemic disease it would still
kill lots of older people and so
the population was kept young by disease
during centuries
and after the 19th century well
you know we we got used to a lot of
these diseases especially when we went
into the cities
uh you know we had lots of people in a
certain
given place lots of people would die
when cholera or some other disease
attacked
but then after that we got used to a lot
of diseases we also invented vaccines
for those who believe that vaccines
uh help us out with immunity and so on
but the issue is that today we don't
have any childhood diseases
they don't kill nearly as many as they
would kill at the beginning of the 19th
century
in the 1800s half of the children
under the age of five would die because
of childhood diseases
they had no defenses today we are the
descendants of those who lived and
procreated and gave us their defenses to
us
to most of the population there are
people still out there that have no
defenses but in general the population
has been
immunized so we don't die of diseases
today
we die of old age diseases such as heart
ailments
uh diabetes you know the
arthritis like in my case i have
arthritis so you know
we die of different type of diseases and
they have to do maybe with genetically
how we're genetically structured you
know at some point you gotta die
because you can't live forever and so
genetics
you know sets in um
so what's happening is the following
this is this is what the population of
the earth is looking like
okay uh we're
it's it's the the pyramid is inverting
okay the question is how fast it's going
to
invert that it is inverting and that we
cannot do anything about it i think
anybody
nobody can do say anything about that
okay i'll i'll challenge anyone who says
that
we can do something about it no we can't
women can no longer
not will men but women plural
women cannot do anything about uh
procreation anymore okay we're done with
procreation
once you come to the cities there's no
possibility of having children again
okay so is africa gonna triple by the
end of the century absolutely not
because even in nigeria countries that's
growing so big
so fast today uh everybody's gonna be
moving to big cities to lagos and
you know the the main centers they're
gonna move from the country to the city
that transition is going on right now
it's going to
accelerate later on as much as it can
and once the people get into the cities
the women will not have children when
women the couple
couple will not have children they might
have one or two they're not going to
have eight or ten
anymore that that era is going to be
gone so no
there's no way nigeria is going to
triple for example its population by the
end of the century
never going to happen and again it's the
transition that's going to kill
birthing once we're in the cities no
children
okay so uh yeah what can i say you can
see the population decline has uh
the growth rate there by maybe mid
century we're going to be growing at
zero population growth as it's called
there's going to be no growth of
population on earth
we're not creating cities the big
countries the important countries
are no longer having children in fact a
lot of them are already in negative
growth
here in europe spain italy they're
already in negative growth
and uh so if the important countries of
the world
part of that g20 okay if uh
if they're not going to have children uh
are they gonna
live out of immigration just allow
people from other countries to invade
them and
uh do maybe the menial work at the
beginning and then
rise up and change the composition of
society
don't think that's going to happen uh
there's going to be immigration there is
immigration
trickled right now i don't think they're
we're going to evacuate nigeria
by bringing all those people here to
europe okay
so the big problem we're not creating
cities we don't create
cities we're not um
going to expand our population the
existing we die with the existing cities
i don't think russia will create a city
in siberia
just to populate the country i don't
think argentina is gonna
populate the pampas you know form a city
over there it's never gonna happen
whatever cities you see on the world
today that's how the
world is going to end with those cities
they're just going to be filled with
more people
okay that's my take on that okay
a second question today is uh
not necessarily related but it's related
to the economy
and that's what i'm referring to when i
say
is the united states government going to
collapse is it
is it's um are its colonies
uh extra official colony they're all
colonies but
you don't want to call them that because
it's not a very good name
uh they have the united states has a lot
of influence over those countries
uh economic influence especially right
they have to bow down to a lot of the
new demands the united states has
because they do commerce with the united
states
and the united states otherwise takes uh
revenge
okay so you know it's it's all the same
empire okay so the question is is that
empire
receding now and if it recedes you know
if you don't grow you die
so uh if the united states is receding
economically at least
maybe not militarily but economically uh
can it continue to recede recede receded
until when until it collapses
or will there be a war and
we get back to normal human behavior
yeah there could be a war but if there
is a war it's an economic
issue so it always comes down to
economics okay here's another
related issue to economics we have
crypto crime today
new type of crime you know jesse james
with rob banks
and trains especially trains
uh bonnie and clyde they drop banks you
know those are the good old days nobody
robs banks anymore
i don't think well some people do but uh
it's a lot easier to catch them and
it's not as glorious as it used to be
like it's
an anachronism if you go and rob a bank
no you do it the
the modern way you do crypto
scamming okay and they found a crypto
mining farm in the ukraine
3 800 playstations and 5 000 computers
you see a picture there the guy had all
these computers there
to do crypto mining okay so uh
pretty soon it's gonna be big business
to to get into this
crypto crime uh world
and a lot of people just like people get
into
buying cryptocurrency a lot of people
are gonna get into
cryptocrime because it's harder to
detect
you know it's no longer chasing across
the state line
behind uh you know dillinger or bonnie
and clyde
no now you've got a different situation
you got these anonymous people out there
and
they are using computers uh
to attack the system and you can't
always find them so easy in fact there's
several crimes lately uh where companies
have been forced to pay
ransom to get their data back in the
united states
the united states accuses russians and
so on yeah so
uh cryptocrime is on the rise and here's
another uh
crypto uh news crypto scammer
sentenced to 15 years in prison swedish
swedish a guy from this
from the european union an educated guy
a uh a uh person who was
educated also to respect the law
and so on swedish citizen roger
nielsen jonas carlson defrauded
thousands of victims and stole tens of
millions of dollars over a period that
lasted almost a decade
sentenced to 15 years in prison or to
pay his victim
16 million dollars etc and he did it all
through
crypto accounts he they caught him in
indonesia and asked for his extradition
uh
so crypto crime is gonna is on the rise
and will continue
to be under eyes because it's uh
considered by
many programmers and so on that they can
get away with the crime that they won't
be caught
so i get ready for that that's another
thing and the question is
uh you know we've come a long ways from
the days of
biblical ruth you know being paid with
barley
uh we're no longer in those days today
you know we have cryptocurrency
this abstraction that
governs the world or that is slowly
gaining ground
on the traditional coins fiat money and
so on
uh is that going to break the world bank
yeah the piggy bank you know the
treasury of the world the fact that we
have all this
coinage out there that at least so far
is not
regulated you know think about it uh is
this out of hand this
cryptocurrency should it be regulated uh
or should we let the market system
govern
and those who commit crimes go to prison
if they're caught
okay so think about that okay um
one going to the
neanderthals fellow ass or says
yeah the little rate never happened it
must have been known to stick it in all
sorts
no doubt there is doubt your assumption
that
nyans and dinos
[Laughter]
i'll get it right in a second uh we're
entirely
uh different species respectful of
proto-human femmes
honor is a little presumptuous no it's
not a question of
being uh for some um
you know of them respecting the honor or
anything like that
what we're talking about is two
different species
neanderthals are a different species uh
and so the question for you
is do lions do it with tigers assuming
you
let go of a tiger in line territory or
lion or
or lion tiger tory whichever way
do you think uh the lion will mate with
a female out there
or vice versa no believe me
they'll attack that other species
and kill it even though you know
um there are ligons and ty what is it
uh in ligons and
thai not tigers thai tions
you know the mixture of lions and tigers
we have them in in the zoos
you know under control of man out there
in the wild
doesn't happen okay you don't have that
in in the wild okay
you might find i don't know maybe some
uh exception out there it's not the norm
okay
to say that neanderthals would sleep
with uh uh
women women and a human woman
or a man like this guy running away from
from the neanderthal gal you know
no i don't think so and then again uh
one night stand does not produce
the disappearance of a species in order
for there to be a disappearance of a
species
if every member of the neanderthals
at some point had to have sex
reproductive sex with humans
it can't be just a group because if the
other group continues to have sex among
themselves
you know within the species then we
should see neanderthals alive today
if we don't see them is because every
last neanderthal who
procreated uh would have had to have sex
with our human with a human species
and good luck with that one if you think
that ever happened
no absolutely not and that's why the
admixture
theory is bunk it's absolute bunk
it's only put forth by geneticists
because they created a cottage
in this trinity for themselves they are
the rulers now
of neanderthal extinction they tell you
what to believe they say yeah we
we proved it we got two percent
neanderthal dna
yeah i mean we had a common ancestor
eight hundred thousand years
or so ago no wonder yeah
does that mean that they had six fifty
forty thousand forty five thousand years
ago
uh i don't think so not in the wild not
when uh
neanderthals were the worst enemies of a
neanderthal humans were
the worst enemies of humans and if a
human you know clan
walked into neanderthal territory
i'm sure the neanderthals would have
liquidated them
entirely maybe eating them thinking
they're some kind of animal another
animal to hunt
okay so no uh i don't think it ever
happened
okay uh along the same lines fella says
there are people who re propose a
fundamentally different theory
europeans are in fact neanderthals with
a little bit of eggnester
from homo sapiens africans in other
words uh
humans came into
europe to enrich the already uh
morphine uh europeans and you go to that
site the site that he mentions uh
differences between neanderthal skeleton
and the so-called modern humans are
certain yeah there are many differences
between them
and more than anybody in
especially in genetics
these geneticists are willing to admit
you know they say yeah we were different
but we had sex
well you know that's uh like a weird
kind of theory you know
if if we if we're so different that you
can tell the difference
even today 40 000 years later just by
looking at their
skeletons they must have been quite
different in real life
quite different but what did we do well
in the end with all this century
20th century especially right suffered a
tremendous evolution
the biggest evolution i've ever seen in
any animal species
uh here you see it at the beginning of
the century
marceline boule french guy
he made this picture
of uh nathan what he thought the
neanderthal looked like the one on the
left
and he looks more or less like a gorilla
and there's the skeleton he got that
idea from uh you know he worked together
with
um a paleontologist
and from that skeleton from that uh
obviously that's already built up but
that's what the guy apparently looked
like when you put a little skin over him
but from the skull itself this is what
boule came up with on the other hand
today
we have this lady elizabeth danes and
she's a french lady and what she does is
she
tries to you know
reproduce reconstruct uh faces and
bodies
of old neanderthals and this is what she
came up with
for the same skeleton she also looked at
that skeleton she came up with
this guy on the right and he's a little
bit different than the guy on the left
okay among them the hair and a lot of
things that
you know are kind of uh hidden like
behind the
beard and and the whiskers and so on
so the question is you know did uh
humans look the
neanderthals looked like the guy on the
left or like the guy on the right
who is right and yeah if you look at
some of the
pictures we see today of neanderthals in
fact all of them you can see they look
pretty much like humans
okay they've humanized them over time
and this is not what you would have
found at the beginning of the
20th century the question is whether
this is the
right notion of what the neanderthals
look like
another thing that they do is they
clothe
neanderthals when it's absolutely clear
that
neanderthals could never have used
clothes okay there are no needles as i
explained the other
day and we found obviously no clothes
and i don't think you'll ever find any
you won't find any boots
uh you know and the needle
i mean with all the sights they found
from neanderthals they found all kinds
of tools
and weapons never have they found a
needle
short or long you know fat or skinny
they've never found a needle and that is
strange you would think that at least
one needle would have survived out of so
many sites
that's not the case and so again you
know nando's i had no reason to dress up
but we always dress them up
i guess the actors don't want to be nude
on the screen or something
and yeah this is what what you'll see
out there and
so what they've done is they made the
neanderthals look like us
in great measure and the more we go into
the future the more they'll look like us
because they're trying to push this
interbreeding theory the admixture
theory that's the only reason for that
okay another fellow brings up the issue
who says the out of africa
theory has been debunked decades ago
and that otto africa for those of you
who are not familiar is that humans
essentially were born
originally in africa they migrated far
east
all the way to china and also to europe
where we allegedly
met the neanderthals okay this is the
theory today and this fellow is
criticizing the out of africa theory
well uh it's not debunked debunk
for whom for you okay uh
unless you unless the proposal
is irrational then you cannot say it's
debunked
uh irrational you can say it's
irrational yeah if it is irrational
otherwise there is no such thing as
debunking
in science we we might use that word
informally
but debunk means that you don't believe
in a theory
okay so it's either irrational doesn't
belong in science in the first place
if it's rational uh the assumption
is rational well then it can be
incorporated into science
and you can build upon that and so we do
have
a criterion or create a set of criteria
for what is rational okay and the main
one i want to put to you out
is that third one says theory is
inconsistent with or doesn't follow from
the assumptions
that would be considered irrational and
so as long as the theory here
you know follows more or less the um
the assumption then there is no problem
then uh
there should be no complaint as far as
uh or calling it debunked
debunk only means that you don't agree
with it okay
okay uh let's continue here um another
issue related to extinction
are we gonna leave the planet are we
gonna have
uh be a space-faring uh civilization
are we going to build ships and orbit
the earth are we going to go to mars are
we going to go to the moon or
who knows well some people are proposing
going to venus let's terraform venus
they say it's a better candidate than
mars
it's closer when it's closer to the sun
also
that's good you get heat instead of cold
out there away and
far away in mars it's got co2 just like
mars
but co2 here in venus a little more
dense quite a bit more dense it would
crush you if you were
on the surface of mars that's how dense
the atmosphere is we would not be able
to resist it
okay it's also a lot hotter i think like
450 degrees centigrade
and they say okay but it's got its
advantages it's got almost the same size
as earth the same
mass that means we don't have to worry
about gravity like we would have
in the case of mars mars is you know
like
uh anywhere from a quarter to a third of
the earth
in in mass it's a small planet
and so it doesn't have the gravity that
we have here on earth
so that would be a problem forever the
other one is that you know it's got a
very
light co2
atmosphere and so you would need to
turn that into oxygen but then again the
gravity would not be there to hold
that air and second um
you know the pressure would not be the
same as here on earth
so there are several problems with mars
a lot better candidate is venus the only
problem with venus
is um to terraform it like they suggest
they're turning
it into what it is today to what it
should be in the future
it's going to take like 200 300 000
years
uh at least with the technology we have
today with the
notion that we have of how to convert
chemically you know
one atmosphere into another co2 into o2
for example
okay so that would take 200 300 000
years
i'm not even sure we're going to get
past the next 30 years so
i think you should forget about that but
it's for people who do a lot of star
trek and very little
scientific real scientific study they're
into technology
not into science into trying to figure
out whether it even
is within the laws of probability
you know uh that we're going to go to
any of these planets or
or the moon okay or in orbiting
satellites of some kind uh spaceships
never gonna happen maybe for tourism
yeah and talking about tourism
we had this week also another guy spaced
out
and this guy is a billionaire
entrepreneur and adventurer richard
branson's dream of space travel was
realized in celestial terrorist tourism
took a leap
forward sunday as virginia galactic's
rocket ship
reached the edge of space during a
historic flight from
uh spaceport america and turns out he's
he's a billionaire there okay and says
okay he went up into space he was
floating out there he was all excited
okay
uh and there was a comment from uh
senator bernie sanders and he said the
following said vermont senator bernie
sanders was less
impressed here on earth in the richest
country on the planet and half our
people live
paycheck to paycheck people are
struggling to feed themselves struggling
to see a doctor
but hey the richest guys in the world
are off in outer space
yes it's time to tax the billionaires
[Laughter]
should we tax the the billionaires
should we um tax the big corporations
like i started the uh
talk today is is that what's gonna solve
it
uh take the money from the rich uh
and give it to the poor little robin
hood kind of stuff
or uh should we allow the money to stay
in
the hands of those who are wise
entrepreneurs yeah they have a little
fun on the side
like going into space but they're going
to invest money supposedly and
create corporations which put people to
work
and maybe that's for the better of
mankind
and then there's the issue of speed you
know by the time these guys put a
corporation we're all dead and so
maybe right now is the time to tax them
give the money to the poor
somehow you know through some mechanism
uh fiscal or monetary
and um and
have people be able to make it to the
end of the month
so again it's always that fight between
conservatism
and liberalism
democrats republicans communist
capitalism you know
there's always that fight okay
it's been eternal i don't think we'll
ever eradicate in what little time
remains here on earth for us anyways uh
i always encourage people to do
extinction 101 before 102
101 is mass extinction of past animals
102 is human extinction
before we can talk about human
extinction it's good to find out what
happened to the animals in the past
maybe the same thing's going to happen
to us and we can't do anything about it
okay and a good place to start is with
what i call the homework and that's um
that um you know
the question is how why did the animals
on land that's really for extinction
101.
why did the animals on land die almost
at the same time
as the animals in the seas okay
and so yeah that's uh that's where we
stand on all that
because if you can figure out why
animals on land died more or less at the
same time as animal indices
maybe you have the clue to
how extinctions happened in the past and
maybe you can extrapolate those to men
and figure out
if we can do anything about that same
process okay
so let's get on with the second part
okay
give me a second here
and i'm gonna deal with spin okay
and what is spin well before we can get
the spin
let me show you start the day start the
talk with a song okay
it's the quantum song turns out one
group figured it out
and made a song dedicated to quantum
mechanics okay
not none of my friends by the way i wish
they were okay but here it is
it's the quantum song i call it and the
guy is called super
super position we talked about that the
other day
super position superstition aims with
imprecision imprecision but when things
can't be explained
superposition oh
i love that song yeah my son pointed it
out to me i thought i'd bring it up so
uh
go find it it's called superposition by
young the giant
group out there and they say but when
things can't be explained
when the mathematician cannot explain to
you they just say
superposition more or less like mary
poppins you know when she couldn't
explain something she would say super
califragilistic expialidosis
that's how it work you know when you
when you don't know just say
i don't say something like energy and
that'll
fix all the problems so what is this uh
superposition well i covered it the
other day okay
and it's uh you know a horse stand still
it also runs at the same time
okay so uh
i don't know uh maybe
maybe not okay okay so what is this spin
thingy well
uh one of the visitors to the site here
uh
put this comment out there he says
electrons do not spin
pbs space-time okay and i go in there
look at the
video he referenced and i had already
the idea of
doing spin today so it just came in very
handy and it just coincidentally
and you go in there and matt o'dowd the
guy who
um that does the pbs
uh physics mathematical physics
mathematics
uh program he says the pharmacy says
think of electrons as being connected to
all other points
in the universe by invisible strands
and you see it there he illustrates not
this but this
huh let me read that again uh
maybe i didn't read a problem maybe it
went over my head let's see
think of electrons as being connected to
all other points in the universe by
invisible strands okay and a fellow
makes the comment says it's staring them
right in the dumb
faces okay so uh we're supposed to look
at this
um as strands
that somehow bind interconnect
what do you say they're connected to
right
so he's saying that yeah these um these
strands are connected to
every uh i guess atom
in the universe to all other electrons
in the universe that's what he wants you
to think
where did he get that okay and
here he this is what he illustrates here
and so you ask well what are those
ribbons
you know i mean where did he get that in
quantum quantum was a particle theory
you know you have these little dots
balls
corpuscles uh grains of
sand grains of dust
and suddenly we have this
interconnectivity
suddenly you know all electrons
are connected to all others or to atoms
or to whatever matter is out there
he asks you to think of it that way
because that's what
they observe but don't observe they
can't see it but this is the conclusion
they arrive
at by saying you're supposed to think of
it that way
okay
this is uh what i so uh you know this
fellow is not the only guy who said this
is what i see out there
these are some of the uh statements some
of the
testimonies you'll find out there in the
same line here you have uh
michael disney and he says but the
electromagnetic
theory is not based on action at a
distance as was newton's
space is thought of as being threaded
throughout with electrical and magnetic
tensions uh daryl ebbing
he wrote an important book general
chemistry he says a chemical bond acts
like a stiff
spring connecting nuclei as a result the
nuclei in a molecule
vibrate rather than maintaining fixed
positions relative to each other
so the guy first guy says everything
seems to be threaded throughout
the second guy says you got to think of
it as stiff springs connecting nuclei
uh what did matt oh dad said all
elections are supposed to be thought of
as being connected to something out
there through some kind of
ribbon i guess here's the casimir effect
a field in physics may be envisioned as
if space were filled with interconnected
vibrating balls and springs
and there was a conference in at the
university of colorado
known as electromagnetic waves physics
2000
it says wiggling one charge causes the
field
lines attached to it field lines
attached to it
to wiggle and after a time the other
charge starts to wiggle
it's just like a rope connecting two
rocks
the wave here consists of a wiggling
line of electric
force which you can think of as being
attached
to the vibrating charge
okay so uh we seem to have
uh not only one fella but here we have
at least several
testimonies from uh professionals
people who supposedly are mathematical
physicists
physicists you want to call them and
these people are saying that everything
is connected
but that's not quantum what quantum says
this is what quantum says
okay well this is this is first
this is our uh hydrogen atom you can see
it's connected to everything
um you have the atom in the center
okay that's the the center of the very
center there that's
the conversion of all these threads
that's going to be the proton that's the
center of the hydrogen atom and then the
hydrogen atom
has this shell this membrane
okay this balloon that encapsulates the
proton star
and that's going to be the um the
electron the electron shell which pumps
back and forth that's the quantum jump
and by doing so it torques the ropes
what ropes
all the ropes connected to it from every
atom in the universe
so what these people are saying is that
you have to think of it as
this but that's not what they illustrate
that's not what they believe
in that's what what their mathematics
addresses
uh what their mathematics addresses is
something totally different
okay
they talk about you know individual
particles
and so here's the difference between
them and us this is what
quantum proposes discrete particles
we are the ones who are proposing that
the atoms are interconnected
where did quantum now come up with the
idea that
atoms are interconnected and what is the
physical entity that interconnects them
i mean they have to identify them but
see what they say is something different
they say you have to think of it
as if you're supposed to visualize it as
if
but but that's philosophy that's not
part of
their physical interpretation physical
interpretations is always particle
moving through space little ball moving
through space
that's very different than saying that
all these electrons atoms whatever
are connected physically connected where
is the connector
where do we see that in the standard
model
okay so it's cheating because there
they throw this out but then they don't
follow it they don't say well we
we believe that everything's
interconnected they don't say that they
just say
you got to think of it as if
uh so it's the language that you know
is is really killing them there
okay um with this math continue he says
quantum mechanics has
lots of weird stuff but there's one
thing that everyone agrees that no one
understands it
i'm talking about quantum spin this
elusive little behavior of the
electron
spin will spin there you see it spinning
there's an electron spinning
it looks simple to me i mean you know
why is this so mesmerizing for mr dowd
you would think that he would understand
spin just like i understand or like
anybody else understand spin
there you see it right but these people
are saying that
that's not spin in other words that's
not how at least
how an electron spins okay
so how does an electron spin or what is
a spin
and that's the question matt asked she
said what is spin
well you would think it's like that top
there you know we all understand spin
you just twirl the top and we know we
understood spin
and matt is saying well you know we're
gonna try to find out he spends a
like a whole show there trying to
explain what spin is when it's very
simple there's a guy who also has like
six videos
hour videos like six hours talking about
spin
i mean spin and spin and spin you take a
top you spin it we know right
why is this so difficult and so
we have to look up what spin is and we
go to the wikipedia and here we
find which you know a lot of these guys
use anyways
okay and so what is spin well here you
see it says spin
an intrinsic form of angular momentum
carried by ellen carried you know they
carry it on their back
the angular momentum i like the words
that mathematicians have to
use that have to invent the phrases they
have to make in order to make their
physical interpretations so they carry
the angular momentum which is carried by
elementary particles
okay i hope you understood it carries it
okay composite particles hadrons and
atomic nuclei okay spin is one of two
types of angular momentum
in quantum mechanics the other being
orbital angular angular momentum
orbital angular momentum what is that
the quantum mechanical counterpart to
the classical angular momentum of
orbital revolution okay there you see it
okay
so in one case you see the electron
orbiting
the nucleus in the other one you see the
you can say the skin of the electron
orbiting its center
okay in other words here is what we call
spin
like the skin of the top rotates around
its center
and that's going to be spin and then the
other one is called orbit which is when
you have two separate objects okay and
one object goes around the other like
the earth around the sun
okay straight forward we understand that
okay so what's the problem
why are these people having so much
difficulty in
injuring in on what spin is
okay and here's um here's a
another continuation of that wiki
article and says the following says for
photon spin is quantum mechanical
the quantum mechanical counterpart of
polarization of light
spin has no classical counterpart for
electrons
why not i mean spin and spin and spin a
spin right
the existence of electron spin angular
momentum is inferred
from experiments and one of the prime
experiments was this stern gerlock
experiment in 1922.
they shot a bunch of um
silver atoms through a machine and
then had a magnetic field in
homogeneous uh magnetic field which
means that
the particles are directed in one
direction there's more force on one side
than on the other so the particles are
directed in one direction
okay they wanted to be able to control
that and it turns out that what they
expected to see according to classical
mechanics was a single line there okay
as you can see it a distribution of all
the atoms against the screen
in a straight line instead what they saw
was
two parts one beam went up the other one
being
the other beam went down okay so they
related that to this
property intrinsic property of quantum
mechanics that they say is called
spin so they never saw spin okay
they inferred spin okay
that's important to note no observation
they uh deduced it they inferred it okay
okay um nick uh
lucid you know uh curly guy who has his
own show the crazy show there uh
whatever it's called
uh the
lunatic science well uh what does nick
say
well he says he explains why you know
the electron cannot have spin
okay spinning like a top okay if those
electrons have a diameter of 10 to the
negative 18
meters to be spinning with an angular
momentum of one-half
h-bar okay the outer edge would be
moving at almost
one million times the speed of light
so there you have this turtle of light
okay and you can see the
electron i couldn't get it to spin a
million times faster but it's moving
faster than the turbo that's the point
okay
so light would go slow in the electron
the
skin of the electron right would rotate
faster than the speed of light that's
what he's saying
that's why they can't figure out what
what is really happening there because
you know the electron is a point
particle meaning
it's even smaller than what he's saying
there it's like
approaching zero if not zero itself
because that's what a point particle is
just location
and no body and so he's saying that
same something so tiny would have to
move so fast
much faster than the speed of light that
they cannot imagine
the electron spinning like a top
okay i hope that sank in okay that's
what these people are saying
it spins but it don't
okay so it's spin but it don't okay so
here we
have uh another
part problem with spin and that's that
quantum top spins in both ways until you
observe it
remember uh all
all properties like superposition
and entanglement it all has to do with
the observer
and according to you know
the catechism of quantum mechanics
once you observe something once you
touch it with your eyes or your hands
at that point the wave function
collapses
and so before that it's in both states
the cat is both dead or alive
and the top is spinning clockwise and
counterclockwise maybe it's not spinning
at all
okay all at the same time
until you observe it until you touch it
until you
do something with it then it the wave
function collapses and if it was
going clockwise counterclockwise and
standing still suddenly it collapses i
don't know
clockwise and vice versa you could
if it collapsed too counterclockwise and
so on down the line so
what we're talking about here is that
it's got both
uh or all properties simultaneously
until
you observe it until you peek until you
touch it until you detect it
with machine or with your eyesight god
doesn't want you to discover his
secrets that's what it's all about and
so they keep investigating i don't know
why researching what for the rest of
humanity
for the rest of our existence uh to
for what if they already are telling you
that they cannot peer into the invisible
world of quantum mechanics
then what are they doing experiments for
to find more properties what they need
to do is stop doing
experiments at some point and start
explaining
the experiments and right now we don't
have an explanation
what we have is descriptions and the
explanations are all
irrational and they say well yeah that's
the way it is now it's not the way it is
it's the way it is
if you uh simulate everything with
discrete particles then
it's like that okay otherwise no okay so
we need a new model
that's what it is okay um
so what is spin well i'm gonna give you
a shocker here okay
skin spin is just a bunch of
orientations
and one guy tried to um illustrate that
you can see the electron going around
the proton
and all they're looking at is you know
whenever they measure the they look at
what direction that arrow
is pointing to okay and they say okay
here the electrons pointing i don't know
uh
northwest uh and over here it's
pointing southeast you know and so on
that that's what they're looking at
so it's the orientation to tilt okay
that's what they're looking at and they
call that spin
and it gets even worse than that because
what they do next
really blows anybody's mind they go in
there
and they uh invented quantum
numbers okay here you see them
i like this one because the question of
whether elementary particles actually
rotate is ambiguous no it's not
ambiguous they're saying it doesn't
so it doesn't have that rotation like a
top
so it's not it's ambiguous it's not and
then they say
why do they say that it says because
they are like point
point like particles yeah if if it's a
point like particles
meaning zero dimensional meaning no size
how can you conceptualize spin and so
what they've done is something
worse they assign numbers to spin
you say what do you mean you assign
numbers this you know what this what do
numbers have to do with the physical
spinning of a top
you spin on top you give it oh that's
half spin i'll call that a one spin i'll
call that a two spin a negative one
what is this you're gonna put numbers to
the spin of a top
what sense does that make so spin has
some peculiar properties i guess
that distinguish it from orbital angular
momentum
uh it says spin quantum numbers may take
half
integer values like zero half three
halves two etcetera
and so there i show you two spins that i
created i guess
the first one is a half spin because it
rotated only half
the ball just went halfway and the other
ones a minus
fourth spin because it went the other
way or counterclockwise
and ended up there i mean you tell me
what do they mean by spin so we have a
lot of properties to
uh to for this spin uh
it has several types of spin before you
detect it it has
it's just orientation or tilt and then
it's got
numbers assigned i guess to the
different tilts
if it rotates only halfway and then it's
a half spin
what is this so it's got all these
strange properties and then of course a
guy like matt dowd
supposedly a mathematical physicist he
comes out there and says
oh by the way we have no idea what spin
is
okay um but it turns out that
uh they they say they don't know what
spin is
but they use the word spin why do they
put the word spin
if they don't know what it is they
should have called it x the property x
then it would have been a lot you know a
lot of it would have been dubious a lot
of people would have thought okay what
does he really mean by
x but when they say spin everybody say
oh i know what that is
and even though they don't know what it
is that's how they use it
here you have a fellow james nick
lincoln and he's from ucla he's got this
video on the internet youtube
and says how does how do magnets work
okay and he says
could it be that the electrons orbiting
the iron atoms are the net cause of
magnetism
that is could it be that circling
electrons are causing the magnetic field
in 1915 albert einstein von der haas
ran an experiment to check that it was
the orbiting electrons that caused
magnetism
the results were negative in other words
it wasn't the angular momentum the earth
going around the sun
that caused um that that caused the
traction that caused magnetism
but he continues he says later on it was
discovered that electrons had a property
called spin
and there you can see him spinning the
ball okay what is he talking about he's
talking about spin
he's talking about top type of spin
that's what he illustrates
he says that is that the electron was
spinning as it circled the nucleus
so what is he saying he's saying the
electron is spinning like you spin atop
he didn't qualify it in any way
okay so he's talking about spin like a
top spin there you see it again
see how he trolls the ball and he says
it's the alignment of these electron
spin
that results in the magnetic properties
of iron
okay and he never goes beyond that and
he
he started saying he's he's going to
tell you how magnets work
and that's all he says that is the
entire i mean you can just skip
everything else because that's
essentially
what he ends up with he said it's the
alignment of these electron spins
that results in the magnetic properties
of iron
and so you know i i got a lot of
questions there because i cannot imagine
you know the mechanism that he's trying
to talk about
okay there you can see i'm spinning
again okay
so i've got a problem because
here i have two balls okay okay so this
one's spinning
you can put them both clockwise like he
showed there
uh one clockwise the other one
counterclockwise do it any way you want
i don't care do it any way you want how
does this one attract that one
how does this ball attract this ball if
there's nothing in between
except what some we have to think of it
as some
interconnection there elongated object
we've got to think of it like that but
they don't illustrate it they put the
balls and they say this one affects that
one
i want to know the mechanism what is the
mechanism they say well you got to think
of it
as if you see how they're doing it
so they're cheating because that's not
nowhere
to be found in quantum it's nowhere to
be found in the standard model
okay but that's how they they illustrate
it that's how they
mimic it okay and you say okay
what is that ribbon that thing that
connects the two electrons or atoms or
whatever
and that's where they say well you you
only have to think of it as if
and that's the end of it there's no more
than that so uh yeah
the big problem of quantum mechanics is
action at a distance specifically the
force of
pull how do you pull from a distance how
do you affect how does this particle
affect that particle
from a distance without any physical
mediator
the guy who does that is introducing
spirits in that same space
there is no other way of looking at that
you're using black magic to get your
theory across your mechanism across
how does the rope model do it man ours
is simple
okay how a magnet attracts another you
have the threads
and they do spin okay they spin
clockwise or counterclockwise
when they spin both clockwise and then
they're attracted
and when one of them is turned around
you'll see this in a second
we'll have repulsion why because you
have blue against blue meaning clockwise
against counterclockwise
that's what happened now they push each
other away so it's very straightforward
you see the mechanism you don't have to
imagine it uh beyond what you see there
okay so if you want to know why two
magnets attract and repel there you have
it you have these
threads that are swinging around that we
cannot see or touch
okay so there's no purpose in running
experiments
we have to explain how mother nature is
doing this trick
okay that's all we have to do and yeah
it's uh it's uh
one of these things that we're not going
to solve by going to the lab okay
okay so what are my conclusions about
the so-called spin
here they are okay
spin is another mysterious property that
quantum particles enjoy
okay together with what uh we had
entanglement we had superposition
um the coherence
uh the cat schrodinger's cat
you know he's dead and alive we have all
these little properties and this is just
another one of those
mysterious properties why is it
mysterious
it's mysterious because they cannot
explain action at a distance
you can't do that with particles and
that's what quantum is
quantum means particle means you know
it's a particle theory
you cannot explain this with ex discrete
particles that's what they have to
abandon
but the mathematicians love particles
because the particle is simply a
location it's an equation that puts a
a value there and they can put that in
an equation
if you put a ball they can't put the
ball in the equation they have to they
they have to put in a number so they put
the word energy or they put
mass or force or whatever and they have
values for this they can play around
without any equations
and so now you're going to tell them
after 100 years that
there are no particles no
wave function collapses is that what
you're going to tell them
no of course they're not going to buy it
because it destroys their entire
religion
completely and yeah i'm saying religion
that's the correct word
because it's a religion because all the
explanations that they're giving you
are irrational and they believe in them
and they vouch for them they said these
uh
theories these mechanisms have been
proven
and when you say well how do you prove
something you cannot even imagine which
is irrational they say well that's
philosophy anyways
and that's it and that's the end of the
story for that okay so
mysterious in this case very mysterious
because they cannot even describe
spin i mean if they could at least
describe what spin is but they cannot
they cannot define or describe it
they cannot okay and
of course then they cannot explain it
why because
it's an irrational mechanism they're
using black magic
they're saying that a zero dimensional
point particle
has no body no size no dying no diameter
no radius no
dimensions is spinning
so what is it that is spinning please
draw it for me so that i can visualize
it i cannot imagine a zero dimensional
nothing spinning
that's what these people are saying and
then uh
they assigned numbers to spin half spin
two spin three
three halves spin and so on negative
spin
goes in the opposite direction i guess
not direction because it's not spinning
so i don't know what negative spin means
i mean half
negative half spin what can that
possibly mean it just
means it's got oriented in the other
direction it was
clockwise spinning counterclockwise i
don't know
you figure it out i can't help you there
particle spins in both ways until you
observe it
that's the wave function collapse at
that point all properties condense to
one series of
properties okay but a quantum particle
has no
size so what is spinning but let's use
the common notion of spin that everybody
has
when explaining so they're going to use
it anyways
as spin and they're going to use that
word spin
because everybody understands the word
spin they think they know what the
mathematician is talking about and you
just saw
james lincoln there saying yeah it's
it's spin
and he's still even with with his little
spin which is not spin
in quantum mechanics he cannot explain
attraction he just says
it is so when they're spinning in the
same direction the magnets attract
okay so how does the electron over here
spinning
have any effect on the electron spinning
here
and that's when they turn the lines of
force magnetic lines of force which they
say
do not exist are not real that they're
put in there just to
explain something but that they don't
exist
so they're saying this ball affects that
ball
from a distance by what by black magic
so yeah it's a big problem and a
magnetic attraction because the
electrons of the atoms on each magnet
spin
so that still doesn't explain action at
a distance
and so the question is so what is the
mechanism what is the mechanism
not only of magnetic attraction what is
the mechanism of spin
we still don't know what spin is but
everybody knows because everybody
simulates it the same way by twirling
the top and saying that spin
you figure it out
okay let's get on with the questions and
comments that people made
here we have a fellow he says the part i
didn't understand is why a
phase difference rotation he's talking
about polarization here
should have any influence on brightness
at all
as i understand it an atom is lit when
it is pumping it rope twists down
its length to an atom and it's and this
squeezes or stretches it
i don't know what this fellow understood
uh
putting it under stress causing it to
relax and untwist back in the opposite
direction on the same road
well i ca i can't vote because i don't
know what this guy is talking about he's
probably
went to some other site and got this
information from over there
uh the funny part about this is is not
this what he's saying here that he
doesn't understand the question
is that you know when you look at uh
interference which is essentially what
he's talking about here
um diffraction i said polarization it
was diffraction
um you know you get the
typical diffraction pattern where you
have two waves
which are in phase and two waves which
are out of phase
and when they're in phase it produces
constructive interference and when
they're out of phase it produces
uh destructive interference and this is
what you'll see out there okay this is
this is how it's illustrated okay you
can see there
uh constructive and destructive
interference but they do it with waves
there is no such thing as a wave in
physics there's no physical object
called wave
wave is a verb and so these people are
putting a little wiggly thing there and
you say what is that wiggly is
is that a string is that a thread that
you're moving up and down what is that
and and they illustrate it but they
never tell you what it is
because there is no such thing as a wave
they called that away well what is it is
a string a thread
or wire what is that curticue
and so you know they don't tell you what
it is they say it's a way but the point
here is that
nobody asks the question says okay i
understand that when they're out of
phase
it's constructed a destructive
interference when they're in phase
it's constructive interference we're
done and every everybody walks away
nobody asks any questions
and here i'm showing the same thing i
put an object there i put the rope which
i've illustrated already several times
and this guy says i don't understand
well try to understand the the wave
first
okay when you can explain the wave
interference to me
then i'll explain the rope to you
because you'll you'll
go on a faster learning curve if you can
explain that
okay because this has been around for at
least 100 years i'd say
wave interference okay and so if you
understand that you should be
understanding
should be able to understand the rope
model because the rope model is the same
thing
except we do it with a rope now was that
difficult or wet
okay so yeah some people i don't know
they have to start with quantum first
once you understand quantum uh
especially regarding
interference you should have no trouble
with a rope model
okay so i really don't know what the
stumbling block is there
okay another fellow says please can you
give your opinion on mass physics being
an extension of hypothetical geometry
under a different name
i have no idea what this guy is talking
about
i have no clue but thank you
for your visit okay no idea what he
means by that
okay another fella says along the same
line math is reality
nature deals with numbers and equations
absolutely not mother nature never went
to school she never learned math
okay mother nature just deals with
objects
physics is reality math is something
invented by
man to try to figure out to try to
describe
nature okay and they did a good job with
visible and tangible things
but they did a very lousy job with the
invisible
intangible things okay so no mother
nature does not know math okay
at all math has no place in science math
is just a language
it's a language that can only describe
it's a language of
quantitative adverbs only
math has nothing other than quantitative
adverbs
okay no adjectives adjectives qualify
objects
okay red blue that kind of stuff uh yeah
you can uh
put uh frequency or wavelength and then
apply a number to that
but mother nature works with the object
that is mediating
light not with a number she doesn't know
anything about numbers
okay we are the people who invented
numbers
and try to you know apply them to mother
nature's objective world and if you go
to another planet to the planet of the
klingons
i'm sure they have different uh uh
standards i'm sure they don't have the
meter they don't have a kilometer they
don't have the mile they don't have the
kilogram
the second i'm sure they have different
uh quantities
okay or you know
units okay another fella
says the following he says uh the person
said thoughts and emotions affect plants
and i agree but i have a mechanism aha
okay every atom in my brain is connected
to every atom in the universe yeah okay
that's the rope model when i change the
electrical
nature of my brain my thinking in
certain ways it changes the frequency of
the ropes yes
using the ropes i can communicate with
plants and water
uh yeah uh i don't challenge any of that
okay i'm saying that we're connected
every atom in our body is connected to
every atom in the universe
let alone to every atom in the room
every atom of your girlfriend or
whatever
we're all interconnected right through
the center of the earth
okay and so no problem there we
it doesn't mean that you can move things
around i cannot
because i'm in touch with a pencil
doesn't mean that by thinking i'm going
to move the pencil around
because that requires a different
physics the question is whether
by thinking i can affect a plant growth
or whatever
or whether i can affect a
boiling water or whatever okay water in
any way
um that's not the issue
in other words it could be and it could
be not
i i don't know if it's the case or not
and i'm not even worried about
these things whether you know with uh my
thinking i can affect the plant growth
or water
i'm not worried about that at all okay
this is what i'm worried about okay
and which is what i mentioned the other
day with it with the fella who put that
comment uh the comment that this fellow
is addressing right
and says do you think your emotions and
thoughts are physical mechanism
what makes you think it has to be a
physical mechanism that drives the
universe
this is what this fellow put the other
day and so i put in there and read there
otherwise he's using black magic if
there is
no physical mechanism okay so the guy
thinks that everything is done by black
magic that there is no
interconnectivity that there is no um
physical mechanism that underlies
phenomena out there
especially the mediators that we cannot
see for light for gravity for magnetism
so he thinks that there is no physical
mechanism
so essentially he believes in black
magic he's saying we don't have a
mechanism
mechanism meaning objects you need
objects to mediate things
and this fellow is saying that we can do
it without mediators
yeah it's known as black magic and so
the pen falls to the floor
no physical mechanism by what mechanism
do you propose emotions and thought
affect plants and waters from a distance
assuming they do okay we're not going to
worry about whether they do or not we'll
just concede let's assume that mind
affects plants mind affects water from a
distance
by what mechanism what are we going to
put between them the brain
and the plant what are we going to put
between the brain and water
and if the guy says absolutely nothing
then he is doing black magic he's saying
that
mother nature does things by magic okay
so this is the issue the issue is that
this law has to address
uh why what caused it what what
mechanism what
what entity is there that we cannot see
or touch
otherwise you know he's got nothing and
yeah
religious people like him uh believe in
all this stuff
and this is the issue that they um
they believe that all this is done by
math
they use words of incantation such as
energy
force field wave
and those are not physical objects okay
there is no physical object called field
there's no physical object called energy
those are mathematical concepts
that's why energy is
has units and when used by
mathematicians they always put a value
followed by units
it could be ergs or whatever you know
but yeah
they're mathematical concepts there is
no physical standalone
object called energy but they use it as
such we got
so used to it in the uh everyday talk
out there that
people think that whenever someone says
energy oh i transferred energy oh did
you pay your energy bill
so uh people think that you receive
something like
you know i received energy in my house
no no
energy is a short uh hand
for something that happened
okay you gotta tell me what that
something that did something
is otherwise you can't say oh
energy did it or field or whatever
wave none of those words qualify as
physical objects that's why
we needed to define what an object is
for the purposes of physics and it is
that which has shape
the only universal property of objects
all
objects hopefully have shape and if you
believe otherwise please next time you
put a comment
put down the object that you think does
not have
shape i want to see one object in the
universe anywhere
that doesn't have shape okay okay
um oh this was uh
the answer that this guy gave the first
guy okay
the first guy was answered by a second
guy and now the first guy came back and
answers the second guy again
says there is a electromagnetic field we
can measure that is produced by our body
what is field a physical quantity
okay so field cannot do anything there
is a singularity with one side of it
acting like a multiple kline bottle on
steroids okay i don't know what this
guy's on
but singularity a point at which a given
mathematical object
is not defined so we can't use the
singularity as anything it's not a
physical object it's not a thing
it's a concept in the irrational concept
okay
then a holographic fractal with one
center is the nature of connectedness
what's a factor a subset of euclidean
space with a fractal dimension
that strictly exceeds its topological
dimension
yeah fractal is a mathematical concept
has nothing to do with physics so you
cannot say that
a fractal has anything to do with
connectedness
okay it's not a physical entity and what
these
all these people are using is um
words of ordinary speech or the notion
of ordinary speech and bringing it into
science there's
the these uh mathematicians they they
discovered the word energy
so they put numbers in it they put units
the general public
listens the word energy they start using
it oh i did energy this i pushed energy
over there i
i hit the balls 10 times and it had a
lot of energy
and we treat it like a physical object
then we go back and
get that word energy from the vernacular
from the ordinary speech and bring it
back into science
and then we start talking about energy
as if it were something as if
you can transfer and kick it in and lift
it
and do anything you want with internet
converted into mass and so on another
concept
so yeah uh it's the language that's
killing all these people
okay they they confuse uh ordinary
speech with science first and second
none of these terms have ever
been defined scientifically
and they're all concepts none of them
are objects
and for that we had to define the word
object for the purposes of physics
because these people are treating all
concepts as physical
objects okay another common another
question
fel says rope model should be
complementary to the
electric universe and vice versa
absolutely not electric universe has no
clue about anything whatsoever
and the reason they don't have any clue
is that again they don't know
first of all the main word in their
title
electricity they don't know what
electricity is they even tell you that
they have no definition for the word
electricity
they have no idea what electricity is
and they form this electric universe
and it's completely different than the
rope model because the rope model talks
about
interconnectivity the entire universe
being
physically interconnected all atoms are
connected to all others
that's not what the electric universe
proposes electric universe
uses the quantum atom you know the
little ball
uh hydrogen right using that as a model
little ball with the electrons spinning
around
they don't know why that electron spins
around when it doesn't fly away
and with that two discrete balls how do
you produce
interconnectivity across the universe
you know the so-called filaments that
these people talk about
how do you produce them with electricity
when they don't know what electricity is
they think electricity is what quantum
told them which is
the flow of electron beads how do you
produce
connectivity interconnectivity in the
universe
at any scale that you want with discrete
balls which is what the electric
universe uses
so no the electric universe not only is
unscientific because it hasn't defined a
single word
necessary to do physics which are object
exist
location motion they haven't defined
these words so they're in the same boat
as
as the mathematical physics there's no
difference between them
as far as we're concerned so don't never
mix
electric universe with us please
don't insult us i'd rather you cuss my
mother and not tell me that
electric universe is like quanda like a
rope model
okay how many of these physicists
believe that a pregnant woman's fetus is
neither male nor female and thus in a
quantum state
until being born and gendered detected
via ultrasound yeah i like that one
good ten points for that guy ow this guy
a beer but he's got a second one i like
as much
very good says
says bank informs physicists sir we did
not know the status of your savings
account until we looked
either contain the 20 000 as you said it
did or it did not
i am now informing you that once we look
we found that the account was completely
empty
very very good i love them thank you
yeah quantum you know
what is this it says that the wave
function collapses does your
account collapse when the banker looks
at it collapses to zero
or maybe to one penny says that's how we
that's all your quantum money collapsed
to
okay another fellow or a couple fellows
really pointed me to a video
uh how big is a visible photon
have you seen this explanation yeah i
went in there and looked at that video
and uh this is what this fellow says
over there at that video
okay and uh and what he illustrates also
says the field is the sum of many
photons
okay so is that what a photon looks like
like uh many photons
making up the field then he continues as
we have two continuous coherent beams
interfering
beams interfere beam is a concept uh
what
what is the beam what is mediating the
so-called being
this is a very counterintuitive if you
are taught that light is quantized
no kid yeah it's a irrational
not counterintuitive it's known as
irrational if you are taught that light
is quantized it makes no sense to make
it continuous
either either this thing we call light
is continuous or it's quantized meaning
it's made of little pieces
can't be both ways some people have
proposed chains
you know links on a chains others have
proposed what is it
ribbons i've heard i've heard several
substitutions for my rope out there and
yeah the problem is
as soon as you quantize it because
they're trying to explain
how one rope goes through another and
they think they're going to do it by
quantizing it by turning it back into
particles of some kind uh
ring shape or whatever no you don't do
that we can't
okay it's a long story but yeah at least
it's
against the rope model and the foul says
we are not observing
single photons yeah no kidding and so
he goes in there and um
puts this up there's another one here if
i can find it
oh here it is so it says the following
says when we can never observe
interference from just a single
photon hey yeah of course you can
because a single photon cannot interface
with itself
what sense does that make to say that a
ball
interacts with itself or interferes with
itself because demonstrating
interference
always involves collecting many photon
detection events the field is also
not quantized yeah so so again uh these
this is nothing new what this fellow is
pointing out
he hasn't figured out anything yeah he
hasn't figured out anything because
again all these people what they do is
experiments they do experiments
they think they're going to figure out
the invisible intangible world
through experiments so what is the
purpose of an experiment
if you can't see or touch the mediators
that mother nature uses
and so what they did they introduced
zero dimensional particles point
particles they introduced waves
wave packets they put all this nonsense
out there
and none of them can simulate what
mother nature
okay you need a physical object for that
you need to know what an
object is what is an object it's not
which you can touch
or that which you which you can see it's
that which has
shape once you get over that then you
know that you're not going to supposed
to touch
the rope that is going to do gravity
light magnetism all these other
phenomena
electricity and so on you can't see or
touch
you have to imagine it and for that all
you need is a shape
okay okay final issue
fellow says says what do you
read why do you reject the object status
of shadows for non-standalone shape
when the rope atom shape are just as
standalone
as non-standalone okay what is he
referring to he's referring to this okay
which i showed earlier
okay and that's that you know the atom
is just that uh ball in the center all
the others are ropes converging upon it
from other atoms
so what does that mean well it means
that a an atom is not
cut at the surface of the electron shell
because all the ropes continue on to
other atoms
individual ropes they continue
so that's what he's challenging okay let
me put this over here so he continues he
says uh
i argue not in favor of shadows as
objects but against
atoms tables trees humans and being
objects okay we need to define the word
object for us to follow what you're
saying
otherwise the mind may divide the thread
into more and more objects sounds like
fractal woman
a lady who does fancy stuff out there
counter space what's the difference well
the the first thing you need to define
the word object okay
we define it as shape does the atom have
shape
well for all practical purposes everyday
stuff
we say that an atom stops at the
electron shell
and the table stops where the table has
its
edge you know because we can't see
anything or touch anything between the
table and the chair
so we stop it there does the table
continue is it a discrete object no
because
all ropes from every atom from the table
is extending to every atom in the
universe so the table doesn't stop
at the limit that we can see or touch
so the the issue here is that the table
has shape
as it is without the um
without the ropes okay but
why do we put the ropes well we put the
ropes because that's what mother nature
sees not what we see or touch
okay but what is it different what is
different between this and a shadow
well shadow does require two objects you
cannot have a shadow without the
light pointed at an at an object
so uh the the shadow is a consequence of
light it's a process
it's a
it's a phenomena not a thing
okay shadow is simply
an extrapolation of light
with something in between uh
the word shadow means blocked light and
that's very different than what we're
saying here we're saying that an atom
is a physical object why because we say
it stops at the electron shell
is it because uh i mean if it continues
is it an object well for the purposes of
physics we consider it an
object and we stop it there because
that's what we can usually see or touch
but we have to be conscious that the
object does not stop there
it's for mother nature for her it's not
an object
the only object that really exists is
the thread the single thread
that's the only object that truly meets
the definition
of the word uh object which is shape all
others
uh we have to imagine them as radiations
of
gazillions of atom of ropes that extend
from the table from the chair from the
tree from the rock
okay it's you can't cut the ropes
okay the ropes are there you just can't
see them or touch them okay
and so we say shape why because that's
the word we can relate all
objects with that we can use
consistently in ordinary
physics in everyday physics yes if you
go to
little details you're just going to say
the uh the atom doesn't stop
at the shell yeah correct and we know
that
okay we're aware of that but the issue
here is that
we have to do physics and for that we
have to define the word object because
we can't do physics without objects
so we need the definition for the word
object
and that's what we don't have today what
we have today is the seat touch
and that is not a good definition
because not all objects can be seen or
touched
specifically the rope all the ropes that
converge
upon an atom with that i'll see you
on sunday and yeah we'll see you then
bye